adrian what sort of reaction have we
seen from china
well a short time ago we did hear from
the foreign ministry
in beijing on wednesday morning not
surprisingly they have spoken out very
strongly against this bill warning the
united states not to interfere
in china's internal affairs and and
calling on
uh congress to basically correct its
mistake in their words
and not to allow this bill to become law
as to what china does next
well there are a number of options at
its disposal
uh as you just heard in that report
earlier they can
uh carry out all sorts of sanctions
against u.s officials
in china they could restrict their
travel in china
now when uh president trump signed into
law the
hong kong democracy and human rights act
last week
we saw just a few days later china
barring u.s warships from docking here
in hong kong
it also announced it would sanction a
number
of us ngos here in hong kong but
it hasn't really specified what more it
can do but
there is no doubt that what you're
looking at here is what
in many ways a cold war looks like and
this is
not the beginning this is not the end we
are in the middle of a deepening cold
war between
these two superpowers now xinjiang
is an area of extreme importance to
china because
it lies at the heart of president xi
jinping's
ambitious one belt one road project but
there's only 1.5 million people
who live in xinjiang and half of them
are these ethnic
muslim turkic speaking people the
uyghurs some nine
million of them but there are also an
almost equal number of han chinese
and the two communities as i saw when i
visited
xinjiang last year barely interact with
each other and when you are there
you really do detect this almost
tangible
fear among the local weaker population
wherever you go
in xinjiang you see surveillance cameras
this is the most
tightly surveilled part of the country
where surveillance is all very very very
widespread now the united states is
saying
it's going to prevent united states
companies exporting
that sort of surveillance technology to
xinjiang
okay adrian brown there live for us in
hong kong thank you very much
indeed well let's get more reaction from
china now einer tengan is a political
analyst and government adviser and joins
us now
from beijing uh i know we've been
hearing there that china is
um has already come out with an angry
response
uh just why is china so angry at the u.s
wanting to play its role as a moral
leader
um i think uh the hypocrisy of saying
that
the u.s is in a position to be a moral
leader at this point
given what's going on in the middle east
and uh other places uh
you know it really strikes a chord
within china but
most of all this is uh they seen as a
continuing series of attacks
um really aimed not so much at freeing
uh anybody or human rights but as
putting pressure
on china as its these negotiations these
trade negotiations going forward
now that having said that that i believe
is the trump uh
administration's point of view if you
start looking beneath that uh at the
democratic side and the fact that this
was bipartisan
it seems the only thing that uh people
in the u.s in
politics and washington can agree on is
that china is somehow an evil empire
i don't know if that's necessarily the
case china is not
really doing anything differently than
it has done
for many many years but because of its
sheer size and the
implications of it becoming a uh first
the second world power and potentially
the first world power you're starting to
see a lot of friction
but isn't it possible i know tangent
that this isn't about
um getting an upper hand with trades
that people
are genuinely horrified by the
allegations of what china is doing to
the ethnic uighur population
well i mean there's two sides of the
story i mean and then there's always
going to be a divide on this because on
one side
in the west we view the rights of the
individual
as almost being superior to the rights
of of society
we will go to extreme lengths to make
sure that they are
obeyed that there's a freedom of speech
all of these things
and that is endemic to the how we see
ourselves
but when you start talking about asia
it's the reverse
society is put first all right and the
individual is
secondary to it so if you start going
around in china and you go to
it doesn't matter if you're in beijing
or the smallest village and you ask them
about xinjiang or hong kong or tibet
or taiwan you're going to get a much
harsher
more hawkish view than the actual
government
uh takes the government is actually
taking a very very
moderate line compared to where a lot of
its
netizens should be they don't understand
how is society best served by locking up
more than a million
more than a million of its citizens how
is society
best served by detaining uh a vast
number of people and the other
allegation this is this is tantamount to
an ethnic
a cultural genocide
well from from their perspective you're
putting uh
loaded words in there there's nothing
that's saying that they're preventing
people from speaking uh the uyghur
language
what they're saying is that they must
learn han they must learn
trades they must in the china cables
which were released
function in society otherwise you'd have
an apartheid
but in the china cables which were
released and these documents have been
have been dripped out by the new york
times by the the international uh
consortium of investigative journalists
documents were released
that say memos were given by the chinese
government to never allow
escapes to never allow people to escape
from these camps
that doesn't imply that it's a voluntary
process and everyone's just going in to
learn han chinese
and certainly from others uh from wagers
who have been leaving china
well who have been testifying they've
been saying something very contrary to
that that their family members are
locked up and they are not allowed to
uh they're not allowed to contact them
well from china's perspective what
they're doing is following
what they perceive to be the u.n action
plan against
extremism and that means addressing the
issues of poverty
unemployment uh making sure that there's
education available they
china does not want an apartheid
situation to occur
because they simply as they and there's
some people who
blame them for saying why did you let
this occur in the first place why did
you let
people not send their children to school
only to go to the madrasa
on saturdays where they could learn uh
the quran they didn't learn about
science they don't
uh they don't they they're not able to
speak han
uh pudong hua the standard language of
china so therefore
they're limited they can stay on the
farm because the solution is surely not
to be
forcing people separating families
but and these are these are all these
are all certain points that
that china's right but the other
allegations coming out of these cables
detail charges which are much more
serious and
these are this is the reason why these
uh the
politicians in the us have decided to
pass this bill
well i don't know that that's uh
completely the reason i mean
you have to understand that there are
perhaps different cultural views that
that
the world is not monochromatic china
views this
as necessary steps to prevent
violence remember this is a one-party
system
anything bad that happens is the re is
the fault of the government
and in this particular case they've had
no attacks in
three years so from the general
population's point of view
they say no that's fine this is what
they should be doing they must retrain
these people
even if it's forced they don't care
about that
and the government is pursuing that line
they say that it is better to act now
than to have a festering situation where
people who are limited by their
education and poverty are easy targets
for extremism
now let's take it on the other hand if
china did nothing
and they allowed this kind of apartheid
situation to occur
where these people didn't have skills
and they were basically forced
things now remember there were more
uyghurs were allowed to have more
children then the one child policy
up to seven and in a lot of rural areas
this represented uh free labor but the
difficulty is when it comes to dividing
up the land
there's not enough land to divide in
seven
pieces and then seven more pieces so at
this point
they need to do this i mean they've been
the chinese government is rolling out a
series of statistics
uh 560 and 460
000 jobs created us in the last 10
months
trade up 28 violence
down um you know they they point to the
fact that
since in the last 64 years the economy
has gone up 200 times so from the
chinese perspective
it's all about bringing prosperity
uh this uh what we value as human rights
they say is secondary the primary human
right is to live and eat
well and we could debate this on and on
but for now i know tangent thank you
very much indeed for joining us from
beijing